hello and welcome to this video let's
see what the alcohol was up to last two
bengkos were a bit of a trashing let's
see if he has something new in store
Quincy to was his choice two times okay
might be five is more challenging now
doesn't do it yeah I think your black
ass already quite okay not like it's not
like better but I have no there's no
porn deficit you 5 mm yeah possible but
unsure if it it's really doing all that
much can go and I'd be sick so I can
take a couple of times and then a move
like a six it's probably equal this is a
bit more interesting idea would be nice
to see for now that would win a pawn as
I can take on between nights like nights
you walk we need to okay he doesn't
react to it yeah night see for Queenie
2nite takes be too since two men
material
so he's giving up giving up material
immediately even more I mean maybe
interesting because of the diagonal he
is ok but I take the request and we can
ask questions later
yeah he's probably not very happy about
this move but maybe he didn't have much
much else
okay well yeah here there are funky
tactics queen 85 for example what is
this I'm attacking the rook and the
night made on mate also in the in the
mix that looks good does he have a move
you looks difficult rook more wound
colored white resigns no it's simply I'm
sorry but he doesn't play that opening
well I mean it really am makes it very
easy for for black yeah if you got equal
here I've got a koala chambered here so
might be six he I'm not sure maybe okay
he went went with the capture the engine
wants to play a three immediately yeah
this is better this is better now I have
to go back and I have no tactic here
this is a double attack on both nights
this is a mistake though as now I think
94 should work at least it doesn't fail
say 88 stakes and now Bishop age 6 is
correct yeah okay i can i can give the
exchange in something like that that
still this route hanging and they upon
the engine says this is somewhat better
for like after a short calculation
period and this problem it doesn't work
yeah queen a5 is killing happy that i
spotted that i tend to miss those kind
of opportunities but it's it's really
strong text the rookie text the night it
cannot take it because of mate too much
just too much this week back rangas
killing him yeah that 33 out of three
against
you will the banker in the last couple
of games okay guys thanks for watching